this show is brought to you by the cash
app it's the number one finance app on
the App Store the cash app is the
simplest way to send or receive money
especially when you have friends that
owe you or when you owe them like I
recently cash apt Benton because he went
and got me a bunch of toilet paper and a
bunch of hand sanitizer but he could not
find a low or the alcohol to make our
own sanitizer it's a very long story
that's probably very boring but I think
most of us are cash shopping right now
for toilet paper easiest way to try and
grow your money is with the cash app
with their investing feature with cash
app you can instantly invest in any
stock as little as one dollar and did
you know Dave did you know that the
brokerage services are provided by cash
up investing a subsidiary if Square and
member s I PC well now you know for sure
and as always when you sign it for cash
I've used the promo code Whitney and you
will not only receive $10 but cash up
will also donate ten dollars to The
Trevor Project an amazing organization
that provides protective services to
LGBTQ youth plus ia across America oh
gosh thinking of other problems besides
corona is actually kind of refreshing
don't forget promo code Whitney when you
download cash app from the App Store -
yeah
[Music]
you're the king of podcasts well what is
not true in a statistical sense we can
disagree with me on my own bias I
appreciate it I appreciate the
compliment are we wearing headphones are
we not wearing one of that we're I don't
know I've been doing this for how long
and I still can't figure out no Rogan
wears them and I feel like you want to
talk about you know what just follow yep
I follow a lot of his advice not about
fitness or honesty or living yeah but I
I'd wear headphones okay it's to hear
yourself I think so you feel more
plugged in yes you do when you have the
headphones on I'm gonna ask you one more
question that I usually start the
podcast with which is uh are we friends
yeah I think we are I think we are if I
if I had a problem I would ask your
advice yep and that's what I consider a
friend like if I if I and I have before
I've said like what is this about hmm
that's what I consider a friend
interesting yeah but we're new friends
yeah 100% like we're best friend yes
with the grass like to use a greatest
friends for the Verona has brought up I
have friends now or I'm like are we
friends I people text mean I've never
spoken calling me on the phone and I'm
like are we friends or is it the end of
the world and does it matter what a
vaccine comes out I will block your
number yeah and I feel like it's weird
to hyper analyze it too because it's
just enjoy it for what it is yeah
cuffing season for friendships I really
actually feel like we bonded hard yeah
this last couple weeks because in the
beginning you were the only comedian
yeah that was entertaining the idea of
cancelling show yeah I was all in for
kids cuz I I was kinda like making a
joke out of it like fuckin I don't want
to work there I don't care anyway I
thought it was gonna be like a month I
know I thought the whole thing was like
who are these fucking Psychopaths and
don't want to hang out like I'll take
them on I'll shit and then I was like no
this is the rest of your life yeah like
oh okay a permanent so yeah I was
canceling I was casting
things in 2021 you know I was canceling
four weeks before Corona I was like shut
it down just shut it down what a respect
for China shut it down shut that funny
bone down we're talking like our to our
yeah I guess this was like a week and a
half ago there was a moment there with
comedians where it was glorified and
like courageous and impressive to be
like the show must go on
I'm coming to Royal Oak Michigan I'm
coming to here when everyone else
cancels we show up yeah we don't have
health insurance that we do yeah it was
pretty yeah yeah no it was I was talking
to people and they were like cheer yeah
come on like that was the attitude they
have yeah come on and I'm like well
there's there's bodies burning in the
street I you know the country of Italy's
collapsed you're like dude do you not
long people have waited for the show I'm
like well guess they got yeah from there
I'm like I know the people in Winnipeg
are excited but let's just out of
deference to the systemic collapse we're
all about you but no I don't think
anyone anyone you know it's our job to
poke holes in the official narrative
right so there's comics still doing it
which is crazy like even now there's
like well I mean there's people that are
just like so overblown thank you I think
it's do you know anyone personally who's
died from this are you on a ventilator
no I think everything's fine so it's at
that point it's kind of like yeah I mean
you just got to admit you were wrong
this is not something you can just
double down on we're also a bunch of
alcoholics that had a black belt in
denial correct
shit you know and I think it's also
definitely hard to wrap your head around
the idea that we chose a job that
requires a bunch of people to get in a
room together and breathe on each other
yeah and open their mouths yeah breathe
and there's nothing worse for the spread
of this virus than us
hey like we are the problem yeah we are
the bats flying around country people
flying around this country getting
people to get into room open their
mouths and just go and laughs we are the
bats of America our I mean we're the
worst conduits of that which is you know
unfortunate but that's what it is
you know at this most so even when
things normalize whatever it hate to use
that word like how soon are people gonna
feel safe going back into this
environment
yeah because I feel like you know
everyone's comparing this to 9/11 it's
like 9/11 was planes and buildings yeah
that that's where we had the PTSD around
right yeah yeah no so 9/11 the displays
of human compassion were everywhere
that's right after it happened people
are hugging each other in the
supermarket now somebody coughs they're
your enemy instantly instantly because
you're lucky guy yeah it becomes a real
different vibe or feeling cuz I I've
been around for 9/11 and financial
crisis 2008 I got a front-row seat to
that so I was working in finance and
it's like when you see when you look
back in retrospect you're like yeah but
you could go out to a bar you can talk
to someone next to you on the train you
could share your story and commiserate
now you can't do that and it really does
you sign up for zoom which I refuse I'm
not taking on any new paths and here's
what this is gonna show us I think this
will show us to like the limits of
digital yeah yeah yeah now as fulfilling
as it is digital life yeah you know
there is something about being in the
proximity of another human being talking
yeah you're gonna be like oh yeah that
was nice and also I'm learning I'm
becoming disenchanted with a lot of my
friends based on the backgrounds of
their face times I'm running out of my
friends or filthy pigs oh yeah there's a
lot of people that you know like why are
your towels matching yeah well there's a
lot of people that have quarantined for
a long time now starting to show that
they've been in isolation for a long
time just like I mean for us in our
business facetiming I'm like how have
you not figured out lighting yet you're
your DP you're it out I can't I thought
of fostering a dog for a few I highly
I might do it yeah yeah I can help you
with that much like my brand yeah my
thing I might foster a dog for a little
while just because like produces
serotonin dopamine yeah oxytocin it's
just and and and I was like I'd like to
you know this is selfish but I want to
make content with the animal great saves
a life and it buyers other people to do
the same
yeah I don't know that I could come into
it forever that's posturing is you sure
that's what fostering is did I feel like
that at the end for at the end of the
content I would maybe drown it in the
tub you know what I mean but I've
they're gonna be fun to give them a
little mask you sit on the couch with
them that's kind of the you have a tub
now you're just bragging yeah it's new
Hollywood like sorry
apparently they do that in I've heard
this is a rumor China it no they just
put them on a skillet yeah yeah no in
the Navy SEALs as a way to test you to
make sure you don't get emotionally
attached well you're a puppy and then
they make you kill it oh interesting I
didn't know that I know that Davey seals
trained you and you have to stay
simulate drowning getting water in your
lungs why do but I don't I didn't know
that they made you kill a puppy
apparently like well I have such a high
opinion of the country already and it's
just going up by the minute
I had no idea we were killing puppies I
thought we were just killing children in
other countries but now that we're
killing American pop I thought it was
just you know Pakistani toddlers but now
that it's American puppies I'm upset I
don't like golden retrievers yeah it's
really cheese I'm shar-peis wouldn't you
leave the Navy see wouldn't you go you
know what that's how they weed out the
non sociopaths what I want sociopath
yeah I'm gonna get emotionally attached
at that interested yeah so many comics
we know would also do that's correct
let's be honest if Netflix right before
the taping goes here's the puppy so many
comics that would just go without even
thinking throw it and then just go right
up Nick hey
yeah Oh frozen yogurt like you know like
we can get you a spot on the DeGeneres
here's four York here you got your call
you will drown there mom you can get you
an agent at CAA and that's that's also
how debt like the desperation that we
all have to get laughs was so obvious
when people are dying people are just
like I just need someone and say you're
funny
there's nothing less important right now
than comedy you know what I'm seeing on
Instagram lives is bone shell it's crazy
comedians bombing for 30 people on
Instagram Louis well yeah it's also
first of all all of them are now trying
to be youtubers it's like well I guess
it's not that easy to be logan paul guys
huh you you you all thought it was easy
yeah you try picking up a dead rat yeah
you know but i mean the thing about the
youtubers and i've know some of them in
l.a not not well at all but like i've
gotten a glimpse of their operation they
are fucking in it they are every single
minute of every day they are they have
an entire infrastructure built around
just putting themselves out there yeah
as comics when we get an idea we don't
always put it out immediately we refine
it let's refine it make it good show
like a lot of comics right now we're
just putting stuff out and i'm like oh
this is really bad it's making you
realize how skilled the youtubers were
yeah organ put on makeup it's just also
making you realise it we're different
breeds and that's okay yes that's okay
to be different breeds production value
is not our skill yeah and it's also like
do the podcasts comedic but like every
comedian I know it's all nostril yeah
Chin's all I see is Chin's yeah many
people that we know won't make it out of
this you know they're not gonna make it
out of this but that's okay so what yeah
isolation is not a good thing for
comedians no no and it's it's I know
comedians in New York ready that already
telling jokes on the street to people
that's bad it's getting very bad weird
day for by the way day for the
quarantine they're ready like tap
dancing in front of the subway it's
gonna get really bad yeah they're gonna
have to start putting them down yeah
they're gonna be I mean it's gonna get
so bad I mean I'm seeing comedians our
improvisers trying to do zoom improv
yeah stream oh it's really bad I'm
getting but I also think it's this is
the first
I think you know despair has to set in
yes
what what's really upset me is that
people's a attachment to hope is making
them do this flirting with the idea that
there's a future and then they have a
bright you know as soon as people sing
into the idea that it's kind of done
they will stop doing that and just start
sitting on their couch and eating
cookies alone here's what else that's
what we need here you live alone yeah oh
yeah now I do funny me now why I mean I
had roommates for years and you okay
okay what happened yeah I killed they
came in they came in they coughed first
of all do we need guns
you know you might I mean here's the
thing you live in a beautiful home but
the thing is all these you know all
these people in LA I have these gated
communities like these gates for six
feet if it gets that bad mm-hmm it ain't
gonna keep this you know yeah if it gets
really bad yeah I mean having a weapons
probably the move I'm looking at people
dorm people are saying well the same
clothes most people have it and they're
just gonna start charging our homes I
mean like ants are coughing yeah I would
be more worried about organized groups
of people
uh-huh because a lot of cities cities
like Philadelphia and this is and I
don't know why they're doing this have
announced they're not profiting that's
why they're not going to arrest petty
crimes and what they consider petty
crimes amazing it's like burglary
vandalism auto theft I'm gonna read this
for you right now
Philly police officers are instructed to
stop making arrests for the following
list or what are considered nonviolent
crimes all narcotics offenses theft from
persons retail theft theft from auto
burglary vandalism all bench warrants
stolen Auto economic crimes prostitution
get it ladies and gents yeah so those we
will not be so you have kind of a
perfect storm of like the economy's in
the toilet and now also we've told
people that you can also just be a
criminal yes like like there's people in
Philly right now that are like should I
be
of it but they got fired from Gold's Gym
or whatever they laid off should I just
stop moving wait on the street like so
maybe I'll steal a car literally there's
people in Philly gone maybe I'll steal a
car today
and the only hope you have against
burglarized is you hope that the
potential burglars a germophobe doesn't
want to get close right that's all you
have so it's gonna get probably the only
reason I think they're doing this and I
and this is obviously based on nothing
but my own I'm making an inference here
I think the states want help from the
federal government yes I think they want
maybe martial law I think they want the
military I think they don't think they
can do it as States so I think the way
to do that our administration has left
this to States correct which I do think
we should remind people yeah just real
quick that is why it took comedians so
long to officially canceled their dates
is because unless it's a state of
emergency we theoretically are not
allowed to cancel we've signed something
yes it says that if it's not a state of
emergency or an act of God you don't get
your money back correct
so when the administration didn't say it
was like this is fine this is not so bad
we're gonna get over it last week that's
why we couldn't cancel our day so I
think they want a federal response and I
think that the way to do that is to
either make things worse or give things
the appearance that they're gonna go
yeah because there's no reason let's say
Philly was doing that so they want a
Nevada set in well why the hell would
they announce yep that they're doing it
yep even if you were gonna do that why
just tell cops you don't you tell
everyone in pain Todd's name would you
put that out into the media it might be
the only way to have people stay in
their homes it might be I think that's
part of it but I also think part of it
is like whether they want Anarchy to set
an actual Anarchy or they want the
perception that it's coming yeah they
want people to be okay with greater
interventions and greater like they want
people to be like okay listen if you're
gonna let the criminals run around fuck
it I'm gonna bring the tanks in yeah
bring everybody in so you've got boots
on the ground in New York which I was
like it was quarantine first no quantity
after us it just officially got it today
it was an hour ago
so the shelter-in-place order came down
about an hour ago in New York City hmm
you know you know a real quick back
story of how I got back to El
we were talking it was clear that I was
gonna cancel the shows you had in
Detroit or whatever I get in the bath
and I'm like you know what I'm gonna
just get on my flight tomorrow I was in
New York I was out of lovely hotel right
and I was like let me just stay here and
not panic and driven by fear I'll just
fly out tomorrow I got a text from you
going New York is gonna go under
quarantine yeah I've heard yeah I was in
that it did really you know it was
shutting down it was flights we're gonna
start yeah I got out of the bathtub put
my clothes on buck a sweat
like I didn't dry my body got into the
car went to the airport without a ticket
right I showed up to the ticket counter
and said I would like a ticket please
like an orphan in the fucking 20 crazy
with a little stick in Qatar case of
applause yeah go to the airport I was so
afraid and the flight what when's last
time you're on a plane Wow
coming back from Vancouver ah before
this happened I mean when was that it
was like maybe a month ago so coming
back from New York this move in a week
ago yeah it was so weird first of all no
one was talking to each other there was
no like hey business or pleasure where
no one would speak to each other people
had scarves people everyone unanimously
was wiping down their seat like Jersey
Bros look yo home and you need Clorox
wipe like it was like wow everyone the
flight attendants didn't even speak to
us you know how they're normally like
micromanaging you you got to stow that
you can't have that in front of you
people were lean back they wouldn't even
talk to us
it was so eerie and just a really
captain no Oh didn't speak at all real
and speak at all wow it was surreal it
was quiet it was uncomfortable there was
no excuse me pardon me like everyone was
just avoiding each other elbows in
that's so Chrissy I'm going on a cruise
next week and I'm wondering how that's
gonna be because I do I don't want to
change my life you know what I mean I
really want to just I'm going to cause
email and I'm very excited I say
yeah it's just a fun time to kind of be
alone with myself and I actually paid
for a piece I stole a bunch of masks
from Cedar sinai and I'm selling them on
the street by the way god Bless America
people are stealing masks from the
hospital and selling them yeah god bless
this administration for antagonizing
China the place that makes yes well you
know I got all the medical supplies some
of my friends who are comedians I gotta
tell them I gotta be like you know
you're the guy that sells the masks like
I don't want to tell but I'm like you're
the guy after 9/11 that shows up and has
a family fund that you take you're the
guy that was pulling gold teeth out of
dead people a 9/11 just embrace it kid
he knew it and yeah but it's it's I've
not been on a plane it's terrifying on
the way to New York there were 30 people
on my jet blue on the way back on the
way back it was full and no one was
speaking to each other cuz any service
any water no nothing they didn't even
look at I couldn't even get a flight to
turn to look at me Wow I had my bag at
my feet so they don't even bring me been
putting off hard they didn't tell me to
put my seat up at the end I was lying
down until we landed no one's kind of
cool that you experienced that like I
almost wanna I want to experience it
Anarky yeah it's kind of I feel kind of
left out yeah I mean I felt sorry for
the flight attendants it was just like
oh you guys have it I feel very bad for
them you know my I have people that I
know that our nurses doctors first
responders in New York and they're all
telling me the situation is kind of
worsening by the hour they're running
out of supplies some of them are
contracting this some of them are
noticing there's call-outs people are
not showing up to work because they
don't want to get it I mean I mean we
talked about but now doctors can cross
borders yeah so doctors at places that
doesn't dot doesn't it doesn't have a
lot of cases can't go to place Kincannon
which is unprecedented yeah that's
amazing and you have friends that are in
New York I have friends at her new I
mean I grew up in New York you know it's
my whole life I grew up in Long Island I
lived in New York City for a bad just
under a decade so you know my whole life
my whole world is in New York in terms
of like now it's in LA you know friends
and stuff but like family friends all in
New York City you know I they think it
came from Fashion Week that a bunch of
people in Milan Fashion Week got it in
at least brought it to New York and the
way to LA is this doctor in Calabasas
wrote because the administration's not
putting information out so doctors are
writing Facebook posts saying here's
what we're seeing you know I don't
really have time Brad go on CNN and
explain this job because I'm busy sort
of playing whack-a-mole with Roman lives
yeah and this guide in Calabasas said
that the doctor said that it came from a
family that went to on vacation in Italy
and they wanted an Italian ski trip so
it's like rich people bringing it back
killing poor Pete yeah wow isn't that
great i I've heard that it's possible
it's been circulating for months here
and that people are actually it's being
you know you know people just getting
sick getting over it people building you
know potentially some level of immunity
to it you know you know who know a lot
of people are saying I was sick three
weeks ago
III but I never here's a thing like I I
got diagnosed which strap I remember
that so they were like they were lying
you did the tests I did the tests they
were like it's strep but then I'm also
reading that like some of the players on
the Utah Jazz got diagnosed with strep
and they had a co infection with this or
like maybe I had that I don't know
certain but then some of the symptoms
were people like I couldn't walk I'm
like well I didn't have that yeah people
like I was dizzy and I couldn't walk I'm
like yeah they're like I was so weak I'm
like I felt like shit yeah so you don't
know but but you can get a test
eventually down the road and see if you
ever had it cuz if you had it your body
as antibodies and then what might be
working is taking those antibodies and
putting in something right so I mean now
is not the time to show up to I can you
test my blood I think I've already
beaten this I think I've already beat
man I think thank you soul cycle for
helping me be yeah yeah I so I'm gonna
just not do that and wait and then but
eventually when things calm down I might
go back in and bet you said of curiosity
was I yeah I'm really I'm I'm trying to
stay and a lot of this is this is a lot
of your territory because
a lot of this come from the mistreatment
and abuse of animals 100% in these
pockets
that's exactly work right people always
think I'm batshit crazy and I always say
like abusing animals is bad for humans
it's better our brains it's bad for our
neurology it's bad for children's
development when right azuz and they see
animals being abused and confine that is
how children learn internalize exactly
to treat those that are voiceless and
less powerful than them so it fucks up
our kids and then we get sociopath
running the world but also exotic animal
trafficking is HUGE HUGE and most people
that do it also traffic human beings
there's no one just trafficking Jaguars
it's also guns right there's nobody
who's like we're stopping at Pangos
they'll do the whole are in the same
they run the fucking pangolins crazy
so these wet markets that are horrific
there was a great it was at the 60
minutes piece 60 minutes did a good one
on it and it's there's still 50 of them
in New York there's any life gonna be
closed down they were cool like I they
were cool in the sense you could walk by
you see like live octopus and stuff down
in Chinatown now I think that's over I
actually think Chinatown in New York
City is gonna you know sadly its they're
gonna have their they are gonna have a
long hard road back yeah because not
only those markets probably gonna have
to close but that I think a lot of
people's people are just gonna be
nervous about going down there and look
I that's true I think that you know a
lot of I don't think it's time yet to go
like what are look like silver linings
coming out of this right I'm seeing a
lot of rich Hollywood people be like but
it's so good for the environment like
okay yes but not yet let word yeah
everyone's like this dolphins are back
in the canals in Venice and it's like
that's great my grandmothers burning 50
you know we can't hold a funeral for my
uncle oh where are the swans where this
other swans are back in Venice but you
know what it is it's it's about floating
right by the dead body I spoke to an
actor the other night and this was crazy
man it's like I'm gonna let me let me
read you I don't this is like a this is
a children can't stop having diary
this is like a this is kind of insane
this is like oh I'm not gonna say who it
is this is like a well Mahoney yeah this
is just like a well no but let me read
you what it says first ready I feel
oddly excited about the upheaval things
were getting pretty fucking stupid and
pointless in the world curious to see
others shakes out in who's left standing
so much vanity will go values
recalibrated so I get I get what they
mean but it is from just a position of
like whoa I see a lot of very rich
people in their mansions going but the
upside is I'm spending some quality time
with my kids yeah you have 12 bedrooms
yeah it's a it's a little different than
people living in a one-bedroom I just
think it's one of those it's like Trump
was so gonna lose and then gal gadot did
that imagine and then I'm like no he's
winning again how did that happen
he's gonna win again you know it's he's
actually gonna win again because you're
you you were all singing uncomfortable
yeah it's cringe-worthy but again it's
also where are you donating yeah are you
doing it but you know build a ventilator
maybe get out of iMovie build the
ventilators you know what I mean I and I
know I saw this thing on a very famous
actors feed who was like here's the
bright side air pollution clearing up
Venice canals are clear homeless are
being housed is that even true
I don't know water shutoffs are
suspended right that's countrywide I
mean that's good eviction zorbing banned
deb debt system halted is that true in
certain areas yes to say that it's
entirely being halted is untrue people
are spending time with their families
which most people the dumbest people I
know are now homeschooling their
children yeah there will be a generation
children right that cannot read or write
right yeah the people that know that are
like yeah I'm a homeschooling my kid I'm
like homie you can't spell Yeah right
you're an app yeah yeah it's it's it's
absurd to think of a lot of the people
that I know homeschooling their children
yeah history started yesterday you know
for you it's so crazy that that's where
it is I'm not people are homeschooling
they're chill
children the dumbest people I know yeah
but it is funny when people are like
let's just you know this is this is a
way to heal the earth and it's like
listen what would have been great is if
we focused on some of that stuff when we
had the health and the resources people
don't realize the economic repercussions
of this are so real so let's talk about
that you have a background in finance a
little bit yeah which is what is that
just real quick well I was in I worked
at a mortgage company and I during the
financial crisis but little before the
financial crisis did during the
financial crisis it was a blast and I
was selling mortgages I I sold one to
myself I took a mortgage of subprime
walk isn't right now a good time to buy
a house it's not the worst time no I
should probably set up a little shop in
my you know start to just sell subprime
mortgages again because they're coming
back by the way they'll be back
he'll be back because no one's gonna
have any credit and you're gonna have to
give people homes but um I'm not a
brilliant financial mind clearly but I
you know talk you know I remember living
through that I remember living through
2008 I remember seeing you know the
liquidity crisis you know banks unable
to that's what that first bailout was
very necessary yeah the subsequent ones
weren't because companies just you know
paying a bonus is invested in trying out
like they literally just stashed the
money yeah that first bailout you know
the credit markets were seizing up and
they went to Bush and they said listen
within a week or two if P if there's a
run on an old fish and run on the banks
where you see people are drawing you
know all these money market accounts
they're drawing down their funds the
world economies will crash and that I
mean the American economy will crash
within a week and then within two to
three weeks you'll have the world
economy crash so you need to do
something to shore up the financial
system so they dumped I think the first
bailout tarp one was like 700 billion
dollars what's amazing is they just
threw around that amount of money even a
little more than that at the stock
market and it did nothing so that's not
even working
that's not even working any but things
are so bad and people's sentiment is so
negative that like that stuff doesn't
work as well anymore
and we've never entered a situation like
this where we've told everyone to go
home like you know in in mimosa of these
even if you go back to the Great
Depression is sort of unprecedented so
we don't know you know how we're gonna
get out of this we're considering things
that we never would have considered
universal basic income you be eyes on
the table you know taking an equity
stake in certain large industries you
know is on the table partial
nationalization of certain things
whether it's the airlines or something
nationally the nationalization means
making something like what's privatized
in a yeah public yeah and that's none of
that's ever really been on the table
before in a real way so to see even
those things even them then being
considered is wild and you say it's it's
really bad you know I mean we don't yes
Treasury secretary said like we cannot
unemployment getting a twenty percent I
crazy I I laugh when I'm uncomfortable
we all do that's why were comedians
right I remember one time I was working
on a TV show and a guy was telling me
about his mom's had sinus cancer behind
her eyeball yeah and they had to dig out
the eyeball and she was he was like I
need to take some and I could not stop
laughing it's a usually it because it
was just the most horrific thing I'd
ever heard and I like had to go for a
walk and collect myself and stop
thinking about an eyeball getting dug
out to get a cancer out and they were
trying to put the eyeball back on just
to give you an idea that that eyeball
digging is so much better than what's
about to happen in this country like
people's eyeballs getting dug out is so
much preferable preferable I don't think
you can get it through that yeah that's
why in a few months man we're all gonna
have to kind of go back to work I mean
listen here's the reality that we can't
have a shutdown for four to six months
will destroy the economy can't happen
we're gonna have to start going back to
work in whatever however that long
hubble's however that looks I mean the
reality is if nobody has the virus but
nobody's eating that's also not good
yeah start so we need some level of
business to kind of come back so schools
will be done digitally well businesses
be done digitally a lot of them yeah but
the service industry which was I think
the hardest hit
cannot be done digitally so that's
anyone that works in a hotel a
restaurant on a cruise ship at a resort
era Airlines that's any tutor that's any
personal trainer it's anybody that works
at a gym it's anybody that does your
nails or your hair or any you know
treatment for you any person elicits all
of those things are contingent on the
ability to leave a home and if they
don't have that you know what are we
gonna do so I mean that the concerts
events the comedians entertainers all of
Las Vegas like we're talking about
entire swaths of the economy that are
going to be unable to function unless
you know we have eventually some type of
lift it's now the time to invest in
Holograms yeah poor clown are not
Holograms there for a while no this is
this is the top well nobody's gonna you
know nobody's gonna be out go out to see
the hologram either I mean you know I
mean there's gonna be now's the time to
invest in something yeah that's where
you gotta ask yeah I mean potentially
some of these drug companies that one of
them might have an antiviral that works
on the virus or maybe you invest you
know things like Boeing you're not gonna
you know Boeing stocks down 60% Boeing's
not going anywhere it's tied into the
military I'm gonna invest right now yeah
what do I do
I mean like things like Boeing or
obviously that's never gonna go anywhere
airlines will come back I said over the
next three or four weeks would be great
time to start putting money to work in
this environment yeah markets are down
35% he's right there moving money into
your investing that email from the car
he lives in he's just like sleeping he's
just sleeping in a car he's like Whitney
now will be the time to start making
your money work you know he's outside
he's in a Jollibee parking lot he's like
Whitney it's time to you know he's like
he's like there's so many opportunities
maybe I live in your home maybe I should
just come live in your house because
there's so many opportunity I want to
walk you through this that's a level of
service I'm willing to do this from
downstairs from the house ninjas but on
the market yeah so if there's any way
that I could just come with my family
and live with you yeah if you if you
have I've thought about like should I
put a few dollars into certain things
what would you do right now if I get
if you had $500 where would you go well
500 you know Boeing Boeing down 60%
Boeing's not going anywhere at me i
Boeing is I mean you tore the
military-industrial complex like if
Boeing is not valuable that means the
country's over so things like that
things like you you would look at like
you know Airlines things like that that
are coming back I mean you know they are
gonna bail out some of those industries
they are gonna do a corporate bailout of
Airlines and certain travel industries
and things like that and then maybe some
of these chemical stock and you know
anything that's security biota yeah like
that that's gonna be huge people don't
want to feel safe yeah I mean all that
shit you know people gonna want to feel
safe I also think the world that emerges
from this is it cleaner one interesting
and a one where you know if there was a
company making infrared things to detect
people with fevers I would invest in
that yeah I would invest in you know
companies that are thinking about making
arenas in public places safer yes you
know things like that more you know
cleaner those because the future is
gonna be nobody's ever gonna walk into
an arena stadium again without thinking
about as thinking about it's like the
way we all still sort of when we go on a
play still think a little bit I always
terrorists on there so I don't have to
perform at the funny bone in Des Moines
I'm kidding I'm kidding I'll be back
the but every time we show I think that
a company will you know those types of
companies it's gonna be companies that
are reacting to this yeah yeah I mean
entertainment you know you know Netflix
might go up now I'm surprised they
haven't jack surprising those streamers
might start going I mean that's kind of
inhumane right singer though would that
be great look was like by the way I want
this you're gonna pay now 100 bucks a
month for now that looks like I'm
surprised that hasn't gone up I mean
yeah it's it's one of those things where
it's I guess it's impossible to predict
but this is it you can make you know the
rich will get richer this is what it is
I have money we'll have money that's
right but the people that were like I
was think about the people who were
bartending and I live in West Hollywood
the people that were just making really
good money yeah waiters and waitresses
you know people that worked in Beverly
Hills and people that I see all the time
and go out to eat all the time like they
make really good money they do really
well and what like they are
now just screwed and that was a career
yeah that wasn't something they would do
it like you know New York City
my uncle's the Director of Operations
for a group of steak houses New York
really high-end steak houses those
waiters that stared their professional
servers that's their right so it's um
it's tough to see you know people like
that you know I love restaurants I love
the restaurant business it's very tough
I can't stop thinking about obviously
the bars of what's going on hospitals
but I spent a lot of time thinking about
couples that were like just about to
break up yeah now it's over for couples
it will be breaking up soon I mean
what's going on yeah well you know some
people it's a it's a it's a great reset
I mean here's a sad thing domestic
violence is gonna go up you know people
are gonna start people are gonna start
beating their kids I'll try to make her
laugh now hi people gonna start killing
their wives they're gonna do that
they're gonna eat their wives
cannibalism is coming back wouldn't it
be great if you got a real investment
adviser who's like cannibalism is back
so domestic violence is back as possible
foods is down whether we make the money
work for you in this environment when
cannibalism will return and you're like
good idea
you know how much such that's how you
have to kind of think about money you
gotta be like some people being fucked
is an opportunity sad but it's true
[Music]
this is a service we all need right now
it is called better help better help
with assess your needs and match you
with your own license personal therapist
if by any chance right now you're
dealing with anxiety
what would we possibly have to be
anxious about stress possible
unemployment you name it better help can
help you with it you can start
communicating with a licensed therapist
in under 24 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online online
the only place we're really allowed to
go right now as long as it's a within
six feet of us you can log into your
account anytime send a message to your
counselor you're gonna get thoughtful
and timely responses you can schedule
weekly video or phone sessions it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling I know we all need to save
money right now better help is the place
to go visit better help.com slash
Whitney better health ACL pee and join
the over 500,000 people taking charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional I have a
feeling that numbers about to go up
special offer for good for you listeners
get 10% off your first month at better
help calm slash Whitney the other day
you guys might have seen me run after a
bunch of coyotes in my yard I even pan
down to my Rafi's shoes that Benton
picked out for me my black Rafi's they
are so easy to get on that I was able to
truly catch the coyotes I'm not even
joking
I love these shoes so much because they
help me to defend my property from feral
coyotes put him on ran through wet a wet
thicket a wet thicket and my wroth he's
brought him back they were covered in
mud put him in the washing machine now
spick-and-span what's better than that
at this time of apocalyptic crisis you
need some rafi you can get out of your
house quickly and chase off any
Marauders seamlessly knit using thread
made from plastic water bottles so
you're conscious conscience is also
going to be clean
they're all eltz are comfortable as soon
as you slip em on I can testify zero
break-in period for these shoes I did
not get one blister and I sprinted down
a holler they own and operate their
manufacturing workshop where they
prioritize sustainability love that love
it love it love it this is why BuzzFeed
called them there forever shoes BuzzFeed
approved check out all the amazing shoes
and bags available right now at Roth
East com / Whitney that's Roth acecomm
ro t hy s comm / Whitney's Whitney
there's only one of me I hope you can
also see them on my Instagram comfort
style and sustainability meet to create
your new favorite shoes head Dorothy's
comm / Whitney tada
I just I'm picturing just like couples
and houses being like what was with the
door why'd you just slam the door what
was a couple these comedy couples I mean
can we put them on ventilators I mean
wouldn't the best thing the best thing I
want to hear I'm kidding love everyone
can you imagine now I've never dated a
comedian maybe once kind of you know
imagine dating someone that also didn't
want to cancel their shows you know and
imagine dating somebody that was also
very comfortable putting large groups of
people at risk I just can't imagine
looking over and seeing someone like be
like oh what oh what do I have breakfast
oh I'm this morning like yeah see
everybody's just facetiming someone
doing an Instagram live yeah for a
thousand people crazy
I could never well also get when in the
gay world there's not a lot of gay
comedians there's a ton of straight
community yeah so men and women date all
the time yeah medians there's like not a
lot you know why is that I don't know I
think cuz when you're gay you go through
a lot of shit and then when you come out
on the other end of it you're like I
want to have fun I don't want to go be
rejected I don't want to go be rejected
by a bunch of drunk people I want to
have money mm-hmm I have an aunt I don't
know what happened to him yeah I mean
he's what happened to that guy yeah was
he kind of the first openly gay comedian
I just remember one of his jokes cuz
this was years ago I was like a child
but I remember one of his jokes was like
he's like you should send me Afghanistan
I'd scare them that's when that was gay
comedy was just that that gay comedy was
like what if I was in Iraq and you like
okay you know and that's still a lot of
what it is to an extent but I don't know
what happened to him I hope he's I wish
him the best I can't find out his net
worth oh yeah I favorite things to do
yeah is guess people's Network it ain't
great you know I don't think it hurts
people if they're known and then they
come out as gay
I think there's I heard Alan didn't hurt
her but it did in the short term hurt
her in the long term mm-hmm but a lot of
other things helped her being a Central
Intelligence Agency stuff like that so
that that kind of helps that's kind of
an insurance policy when you work for
the government
m'kay well I'm kidding but she seriously
connected and I fear her the point is
that did you know that in China her show
was called dancing lady that's hilarious
they probably love public on it a woman
that famous and then going to China ever
be like there's the dancing lady yeah I
think my name's elet yeah she she's
legit I mean she did it you know
whatever whatever you you come here on
earth to do in this business she did it
huh I think it I think people might feel
if you're you know there's people that
have been in the closet forever actors
comedians whatever yeah at that point
you you have your whole career it's like
why what are you gonna now what's the
point yeah you know like why come out
now yeah she did a lot of people did but
then I think there are people that are
just like I don't want to do it because
I will lose my fan base or people will
be like why'd you wait so long yeah yeah
yeah I think when Ricky Martin came out
we were all like what yeah yeah no one's
how are you the last to know about that
yeah it's also like at this point it's
not even a thing like it's not a huge
like we're so past gay now well a queer
past trans even weren't like another
remember three weeks ago when we cared
about transgender
yeah people in libraries remember that
should these
drag queens be reading in the library
and now everybody's dead remember
library yeah
now everyone's dead yeah it's well but
with that stuff we'll come back you know
like that stuff will come back right
well no track with the the petty stuff
comes back like I love like every ever
every tragedy everybody you know that's
the same thing they go you know what
this is really gonna make us think about
like you know what's really important
that's what it's about and then two
weeks after it you're like I order the
post mates an hour ago so it's just the
same thing like I had this joke which
never worked but it was right after the
arm the mass shooting in Vegas and
everyone's like the most American people
were the people that you know risked
danger to help others and I was like no
the most American people with the people
that right after that shooting walked
down to the front desk to complain about
the noise there's a little loud last
night you know maybe a coupon for lunch
you know coming here a long time quite
frankly a lot of sirens you know I was
like that's much better so we will go
back to petty we have to we have nobody
wants you listen nobody wants to live in
the energy of after a tragedy that's
what all these people that are like who
the swans are back they these are sick
vampires that are sucking the energy of
a tragedy people that are like the swans
are back
you eat twelve cows a week right it's
great point but the swans are back the
swans also don't know they're back the
Dolphins are back bitch you were at
SeaWorld last month it was watching them
get drugged there was a co-op on Park
Avenue on a Fifth Avenue who's you know
beautiful building in New York they had
a famous nest for hawks mm-hmm and pale
male the hawk he was a famous hawk
everyone loved them people came from all
over and watch them fly around so the
building got mad because cuz so they
destroyed his master everybody flipped
out and pale may hell just moved across
the street so what they did is they
built the Hawks that's back and then he
never came back because he just had
another net like you but he has I don't
care where I'm living you idiot he's
like I'm a killer I go down and get the
I eat here Shih Tzu in a heartbeat yeah
heed the hawk is like I don't care where
I live he just he moved to the barrister
he actually did move to where Seinfeld
move to a beautiful building on the west
side so this is you know things are
gonna I think things we'll have to kind
of come back to know we all can't live
in this you know like space of like you
know but we also are so addicted to
self-righteous indignation at this yes
the same people that a week ago we're
like we're getting all the toilet paper
are now going you guys are taking all
the toilet paper and you're taking all
the masks the same people that were
hoarding masks a week ago are now
yelling at people that are hoarding
masks it's a real thing that's why all
the conspiracy people they're like is
this real I'm like it's real because
it's income its inconveniencing even the
richest people that's rights I'm like
even the richest people nobody wants to
go through this rich people want you
working they don't like that home they
want you work it like so the reality is
like it's a very real thing what are
always in a bioweapon was it like like I
heard this is a conspiracy you're like I
love conspiracies this is the I heard
that in wuhan they do have a disease
research facility they're obviously all
experiment on animals
supposedly somebody in that disease
research facility was back to or selling
the animals they were experimenting on
to wet markets yeah yeah so then by the
way just so people know that happens
everywhere all the time
when zoos when these ridiculous you know
I always talk about these cub petting
facilities these black Jaguar white
tiger that Instagram feed these assholes
who basically breed the animals yeah and
they take the Cubs from the mothers it's
a horrific process anything about how
yeah essentially apex predators feel
about their babies lions tigers and
bears they killed them usually they just
killed them they sell into canned
hunting facilities usually in Texas but
then after the Cubs have been held by
Instagram influencers on fucking social
media and you guys go pay $50 to hold a
fucking Cub right there our immune
system suppresses their neurological
system starts to atrophy they're all
fucked up but they can only do that for
about four months yeah and then they
send them to China in a fucking freezer
bag to these wets but every now and then
you hear a fun story like I was in San
Diego
and they have these beautiful sea lions
on the beach in sea and they tasty you
know so they always say like don't go
down and screw with them like oh you
take their photos or whatever but leave
them alone and there was this girl from
La Jolla who just went and grabbed one
trying to take a selfie with it and it
bit her arm off so I like that dude have
you know that makes me feel good have
you seen the video of the guy getting
eaten by a bear well no - I love that I
love I love when someone gets eaten by
something like the it's one of the
funniest things well it is Darwinism
medicine somebody's got to say like what
happening wrong cool he was eaten it's
great I like that so I get really
excited this is because of social media
and these feeds like black white Jaguar
white tiger Myrtle Beach Safari these
motherfuckers that whatever I'm getting
a gun I'm not scared for that do this
they give people the idea that apex
predators are something you can just
touch and pose with John we are now
evolving backwards it took us millions
of years to not get killed by lions
tigers and bears and now we are going
back to it because we've got we've
forgot that bears are dangerous there is
a video it's it's it's it's really hard
to watch but of a bunch of guys in India
around a bear trying to take pictures
with it and this one guy just got so
close it just started to eating him and
then everyone kept filming and it's
really light yeah he's filming him get
here you just look up I mean please we
can't show it we got us have use did you
see the woman that just jumped into the
lion's den in the Brooklyn zoo
no that's interest you got to get on my
algorithm yeah okay just look up man
getting eaten by a bear this woman just
jumped we can show this picture it was
all over the news just jumped into an
enclosure I did remember this did they
eat her no the lion just was like what
the fuck is going on now what do you
think a line is a line just like what is
happening well here's what happens
sometimes the Lions are usually not the
ones that attack that's a male lion but
also what a lot of people don't know is
that most of these fucking animals in
zoos are on drugs so really yes and if
they're born with where's that start
their parents just the way they're
raised like crack baby
why do they
because they feel isolated you mean
they're drugged I know how it works yeah
I do
genetics load the gun environment
position I do not work so this is is
this the this is an India right we can
just show your reaction we cannot show
this video I think we'll probably be
taken down we'll show it on my show
she'll show it excited for the patreon
if you want to see it yeah show its
buying the paywall
what is this I don't even know if
they're able to show it on that yeah
they will
they don't care oh he's a cute little I
don't even know if this is it oh this is
it this is the one that I have oh Jesus
is that a guy under there no this is the
one I have I was just about to say that
looks like a fake bear yeah that looks
like some cosplay at comic-con okay this
is the one oh this is great there's
morning's graphic content oh god it
sounds horrible too
I mean people keep filming that's where
the craziest part about craziest part is
that people are still film the fact that
there's a video I love it like one guy's
trying to hit the bear that there's like
what what with that like people forgot
that bears are dangerous so does he eat
him the whole thing yeah god I mean what
did he what was gonna happen and what
universe is that bear not gonna kill you
if you try to take a selfie with it if
your face right now he's trying to get
away does he get away I hope he doesn't
I don't think oh now the bear got him
down I thought he was gonna get away I
mean here's what I'll say if someone's
getting eaten by a bear that guy was
gonna die yeah another way he there's no
way this man was going to live to 80
right this man just doesn't make a
decision yeah that's a yeah he's tapping
out watching you get invited pear it's a
tough thing but it's also like your
special tough thing a tough thing but
you know there's there's a lot of you
this is this wasn't completely
unexpected the fact that people that
there's a video people similarly the
fact that there is a video the fact that
all these people just didn't start
running what's happened to us as a
society I know it's it's kind of crazy
we are fight flight and freeze he's
still trying to dis he still trying to
get away this guy I think he still try
to picture he's trying to get on he's
trying to put the dog air filter on he's
trying to do some kind of uh yeah I
wonder what happening filter yeah I mean
you realize people yeah you know how
many influencers have died taking
selfies on cliffs a lot we are to 380 I
think they're a documentary about that
cuz that's hilarious I want to watch a
document I'm making a show like about
this and it is that instant it's about
it's the adaptation of a book called
super sad true love story which is a
dystopian satire about the future great
thing to read if you're in quarantine
gary Stein Girt he is actually just
wrote a book about hedge funds hedge
fund guys and it's basically about
what's gonna happen in 30 years when the
super-rich survive and the rest of us
are gonna you know died of melanoma
right at 30 years or so or 20 years
because lower-income people are gonna
start dying like from the elements you
know interesting hmm
and it's gonna be a crazy time and we're
all gonna be able to essentially have
our credit score be decided by our
health and what that's gonna look like
Wow yes I want to read that it's I might
really get into that super sad she loves
story it is a incredible book I'm doing
I'm trying to get into I want to read a
lot more books during this period of
time why the fact that everyone's so
bored I was like I'm so bored I'm like
yeah what about books right like
remember those yeah what are you gonna
read Charlotte's Web I want to start
there I want to start to build but
here's what's fucked up
I realize when I look back and I was
like you know what nostalgia is what we
are like I'm not gonna binge Chernobyl
and ozark like we don't need to be
watching like super negative shows right
now yeah it's gonna spin us out more so
I was like I'm gonna start watching like
Martin again so yeah
I love that stuff yeah I want to read
something about science this is what I
want to read nice yeah I might want to
read something about like sight this
makes you think I want I want bigger
than politics bigger than I want just a
human nature humanity I want to read
something that kind of contextualizes
what's going on yes so sapiens I heard
is really quick excellent yeah and then
there's a sequel to it but I was just
saying I was like you know what I should
like watch Disney movies like animation
everyone's dad dies in every Disney
movie Disney movies are low-key tragic
very shadow watch Bambi again like like
this is what I watched know as a kid
during more innocent time yeah you would
like Milo and Otis it's not a Disney
movie you know Milo and Otis I think so
it's about the Pug in the cat Oh cute in
a dinosaur
no sobbing the real dinosaur is this
fucking cute dinosaur his dad falls off
a cliff it's like goddammit yeah he's
very stay always need to put a tragedy
in there although you know what I like
doing going back and watching old
sitcoms and seeing how racist they were
cancelable stuff there it's a fun game
to go back like we know number one which
was my favorite show with me a hate
crime laughs yeah like they released my
favorite shows were do you realize that
Three's Company was a show about a man
pretending to be gay right
that's very funny though like that's
such a funny it's such a funny show so
it was he pretended to be gay in order
to live with two hot chicks yeah and he
was like super pervy and then when the
landlubber come in he'd be like oh who
me
like he would do like a gay thing with
his hand yeah it's but it was hilarious
Thanks oh and there are things that like
you you watch the first time you didn't
even know they were racist and then you
go back like Song of the South I'm like
oh my god that's so objectionable but I
just the first time I enjoyed it so much
children with fresh eyes no but I loved
that was one of my favorite shows you
know I loved it was Melrose Place I've
had to rewatch it and I'm like oh this
is the worst yeah it's one of those
things it doesn't hold up at all like
this is the worst show it's the worst
acting it's so bad and I bets mini suits
yeah
loved that show and that was it I just
thought it was a great a show I like
going back that was the heyday of TV for
me
really things like Chicago Hope er NYPD
Blue Melrose plays Beverly Hills - I was
afraid sure friends Seinfeld got into
Frazier I was mad about you mr.
Belvedere was my shit we all watch that
and small wonder okay okay yeah so what
you know what did you think what is
there are there any soap operas left
there's one right no there's Days of Our
Lives these where lives are still gone
when I used to die federal hospital
still goin General Hospital still going
days of our lives should we look up
which other ones uh I think there's so
many soap because that's it make those
chosen but not 40s they're expensive and
they've kind of been replaced by the
Wendy Williams is of the one yeah and
now so what happens to those things in a
pandemic they all shut down right yes
they do yeah yes yeah I mean they could
play reruns and no one would notice
right it's so crazy those shows because
I remember like those shows have been on
for 40 years yeah wild wild wild all my
children I remember those shows used to
be of it I remember and you look back
and it was like her twin that she didn't
know she had like crazy storylines
swings and they would a lot of the
people on those shows would go try to
make it in Hollywood for six months and
then fail and then come back to the show
so they fell into that like half dead
ocean that everyone wanted they were
like they were lost at sea and then they
just reappear on the show and it's like
oh you didn't get that movie part do you
remember when Kelly Ripa really played
the cards right who did she play Billy
she was on All My Children but she
played I remember it was Lisa Rinna she
played Haley Haley
she played hey Judas a button yeah and
now she's yet just got the strongest
core in Hollywood she just finished in
trash you just came hard into the into
the talk show she got it and honestly
here's what I'll say I love I love
someone that earned it yeah sure we're
gonna talk about Hollywood in a second -
I love your insights on it Kelly Ripa
bless her heart
fair and square she earned it earned it
yeah auditions with was it reaches at
the time yeah and they when they do
those calls serious we've always been
we've all been there where they're like
were
auditioning we're gonna try out a
hundred people yes everyone tried out
for that game everybody watch it was the
most effervescent she was great the most
charming she was great well I didn't
love each other they didn't really like
each other they didn't hate each other
but towards the end especially and they
and they were so good on air that you
would never know but it was because they
had some kind of tension there's a
little tension there I know they worked
on the shows little tense
Cathy got along really well yes they did
and I thought Cathy Lee was great I love
her I love she's a drunk and insane I
love not truly adore get around about
that I think she's one of my favorite
people I love it because I liked it I
could like I used to be able to turn on
TV and see her drunk in the morning yeah
I'm just being or hungover or whatever
and she's just like I lipliners a little
outside to live everything about her the
fact that she would sing and no one
cared and he wanted it and she do it
anyway it was like my aunt Carol she
knows my no one wants perfect she the
beginning of people want authenticity
not a little sloppy boy they want you to
misuse the word they want you yeah the
thing that people and I hate to bring up
politics yeah I'll just say our
president yeah they like that the tweets
are misspelled he's like me sometimes I
misspell fish yeah there's a and you
know what it is I I said to somebody as
soon as this happened I said his
superpower was funny yeah it was very
funny yet so funny I don't know if that
works in a pandemic I don't think it
does I don't think he's gonna be able to
be that funny how it works yeah I can
sir yeah yeah but I mean I I wonder if
this is the end of him because I mean
this was a preventable situation yes
whether you liked him or not this was a
preventable and this is just fucking
about him the administration I mean to
fire the global pandemic
not great was not great and look and
when you find out about a pandemic
happening and you can order TAS and beef
up on supplies you do it but when you're
so grumpy at China right have made so
many enemies with your whole thing is F
gine a-- and then you're also your whole
thing is like I don't want to rattle the
stock market even a little yeah even a
little by mentioning that there is a
thing we're gonna have to prepare for
and let's make sure all my friends have
sold their stocks before we are
those those senators should be caught
can you explain that to people that yeah
there was senators Dianne Feinstein was
one of them there's another guy burr I
think his name I mean a bunch of them
James you know all right so does it see
I gotta they gonna hold off on admitting
to the public the crisis so that people
could sell their stocks yeah they sold
their stocks after receiving inside
information about the severity of this
is this illegal that you'd have to ask a
lawyer but it certainly seemed it
certainly seems like it is illegal and
it certainly it's insanely unethical and
worthy of if any of them at any class
they would resign but they don't and
their career politicians so we'll put
they'll either have to be brought up on
charges or publicly shamed I mean it is
Tucker Carlson whether you like him or
not whether you think he's a whatever or
not yeah I there were people left when
people sharing his whole thing where he
goes these people need to be brought up
on charges this is this is treasonous I
mean the idea that you have a whole
country of people about to get affected
by this and you sell your stocks and you
know you know change your financial
position but don't alert your
constituents is crazy are we at the
point where sorry I just put up in my
computer and there's a dead man in a
bears mouth are we at a point where no
sane people will even run for office
anymore well part of the problem is that
everybody has something they've done
they're not proud of
everybody's got a tweet everybody's got
something a lot of the people for
yourself I did tweet delete right good
for you a lot of the people that would
run for office and that would be good at
it and that are capable can make a have
a very lucrative life in the private
sector yeah operative word is private
yes so the idea that they're they have
children they have wives do they want
their entire life picked apart and
destroyed so that they can take a huge
pay cut to go work in the government and
the answer is is no yeah and also you
have to want so badly to be famous
yeah and you I mean these guys are doing
three cities a day on play yeah you they
are and also now all the kids that are
growing up every mistake they've made
has been documented a catalog save tick
tock liked yes or the only people that
are going to be able to do this job are
complete losers that never did anything
cool
that are not fun and the never were
never said anything so that's why you
get these squares like why do you think
you get Amy Klobuchar and people to
judge and all these people are like hey
buddy it's like yeah these people have
never done a line of cocaine they're
just like it's like they're fucking
losers and that's why you get all these
squares because there's nothing to dig
up now that authenticity is the most
important thing yeah people going yup
I used to do fucking blow it was the
trauma that was with Trump a Trump is
such a unique case he's an amazing
communicator he's transfixing the way he
speaks is it almost hypnotic he was well
known to us he was known to us for years
of your winner yeah as a successful
person yeah we cannot forget he had the
highest ratings of anyone in television
yeah everybody loved him and he was
known as a celebrity so he gets the kind
of a pass are our strangers without that
track record that we don't know good
point going to be able to utilize that
same type of thing I don't know it's
remains to be seen interesting like if
you're running because you got to
remember most people have to go through
the system they can't just run for
president could traps existed without
Arnold Schwarzenegger yes but he
couldn't have existed without reality TV
and social media which are the two
biggest cultural landscape shifts that
I've seen in my life meaning that
reality TV made certain things okay you
know it's fake and manipulated but you
still enjoy it you're still enjoying
something you know is fake and scripted
and manipulated there's that this is
something very interesting about that
something very strange yeah knowing that
these housewives they were all gotten
drunk and apply them with alcohol and
they said them at a table and they feed
them all this stuff you know that it's
very manufactured but you still enjoy it
and also the news has started to echo
popular show so news on CNN oh it's
opens like a Michael Bay movie or like a
reality show hundred percent the same
way that Trump's the apprentice used to
build tension with these but dr. dome
yes the news now does that yeah so it's
what infotainment entertainment I mean
there was a book that Neil postman wrote
years ago called amusing ourselves to
death and I forget somebody told me
about it recently like it really does
kind of you start to look at like where
did Trump come from me like he came from
a world where
you know you know and then you look at
like you know a lot of these reality
shows like you know Survivor where it's
like let's put people on an island and
see if they survive they get barbaric
you know I mean well you know what they
do on Bravo and a lot of these shows is
like get a bunch of rich people together
and they're like someone will go
bankrupt Saudis Hospital hang himself
yeah and let's put the cameras it also
happens yeah after as well so yeah not
only is it chicken-and-egg the kind of
person who signs up to be humiliated on
the yeah you already have a wonky sample
then being on camera
yeah that does to you so there was a
course inning yeah the culture through
reality TV that started really with the
OJ Simpson trial that then became part
of reality TV of course thing of the
culture a hardening of it yeah
empathy started to drain people didn't
care anymore as long as it was fun and
interesting and entertaining they'd
watch and then I think and this is a
show that I loved and was hosted by one
of our very good friends Joe Rogan yeah
I think also watching Fear Factor where
people were like oh I'll just yeah I'll
fuckin drink some blood like yeah that's
when we saw how far people were willing
to go yeah and then social media what's
amazing about social media is that
people and especially Twitter people
love the dunk people love somebody
getting the better somebody else you
know people directing somebody gets
wrecked that pert let's just river and
that's what wins a Twitter argument
right that's right not the facts that's
right so that's right then Trump a lot
back yeah and a clap back so Trump
harnessing that was kind of amazing
where he's like I don't have to be right
I don't have that facts I can just shut
it down by saying you're a nasty woman
or any brilliant you did it brilliantly
yeah and and anything that is is
something that comes from the roast
anything that it is impossible to refute
or thunk
you're a nasty woman no I'm not like
right it's it's the kind of thing where
what I used to do comedy about gender
once someone calls you crazy the
arguments over cuz anything you say
after that is gonna sound crazy correct
as they've just framed it yeah and the
more Defense saying I'm not crazy you've
lost yeah but I I wonder if after going
through this people are gonna be like we
don't need to be entertained every
moment of the day or yeah our brains are
wired for attics you know and our brain
is wired for dopamine dopamine our
adrenals are
get fuckin shot and we're gonna go into
zombies but it's like if this does
collapse a healthcare system when you're
collapsing and this is very tough and
very traumatic I think people are gonna
start saying we don't want a fun
president anymore yeah I want to work I
want we wanted Obama we want a serene
wanna prevail ya scurvy ass look yeah
and not even to say nothing of their
political opinions just their the
aesthetic like I want somebody who
treats this professionally and act
professionally I want a guy who when
they get the pandemic yeah it's not fun
and games yeah because the nobody
anticipates a pandemic but people do we
don't but you know it does the pandemic
team and yeah it's called that it's
called it for it for years but it's like
Trump's like well that what's the you
know it's not a rally or people cheering
his name he's like what's the fun in
that
yeah what's the fun in silently
preparing for Panther you guys know
funny I would have fun you get germs you
can't see them stop it what are we doing
I want people chanting my name I wanted
to say we're gonna put Hillary in jail
on your podcast yeah mentioned that I
get all my news from your podcast yeah
I'm smart you're my Rachel Maddow yeah
it's very smart very smart and about
what Bill Gates there was a TED talk
that is very bone-chilling yeah four
years ago he said we need to stop
worrying about war a physical war yes
thinking about bio terrorism and the
academic yes people started accusing him
of being like orchestrating it which is
so now if you're a smart guy who tries
to help you guys that you cause well I
think we all have to start realizing and
this is uncomfortable that large
percentages in the American public are
schizophrenic you know I mean this is
genuinely true I mean they're no longer
able to be treated like rational beings
because they're not just what it is
they're sick so we're all in a
fight-or-flight mode yeah it's like I
went to the grocery first of all I would
have gorgeous Turk you're saying people
weren't even using carts and we're they
with their bare hands yeah holding
loaves of bread toilet paper I'm like
you think you're not gonna get germs
you're going to
put it on the I mean your bounce like my
mother's just kids are frantic she's in
a mental institution I know all about
mental illness and it's like what
America is like now is like if I went to
her mental institution I'm like what do
you guys think about free trade how do
we feel about it it's like no they're
there so there's a lot of people that
are done and it's it's been a 3040 year
diet of bad food and booze and pickled
ourselves and also the water was about
so many things that there are genuine
conspiracies there are genuine stuff and
our media is just trying to get us to
click on things yeah so at this point
you can't even you feel bad for them
you're just like they've been bit
they're feral like oh they're feral
they've been bit it's not even their
fault it's their The Walking Dead and
they're just sitting at home trying if
eating you know sugar cereal I'm just
trying to figure out like who did it did
gates do it poof student loans they'll
get you yeah I mean they really sneak up
on you they really do
refinancing them with earnest could save
you money or lower your monthly payment
and it only takes two minutes which I
think we all have that kind of time
right now all of a sudden I've got two
minutes lying around if you're paying
the same rate you were when you
graduated the odds are that you could
reduce your monthly payment and save big
big Bank even if you have refinanced
before today's low rate environment most
people can say by refinancing again
earnest is the easiest way to refinance
your student loans saves you time saves
you money you can even combine federal
and private loans that sounds really
complicated they make it easy imagine
having one single monthly payment with
one low rate if you've already refinance
your loan that's no problem
earnest doesn't care you can still be
eligible to lower your interest rate
again start saving today
yeah our listeners get $100 cash bonus
which I think we could all kind of use
right now when you refinance a student
loan at earnest calm / Whitney that's a
hundred dollars cash bonus when you've
refinance a student loan at earnest calm
/ Whitney go to earnest calm / Whitney
today
boy is this ever Lane I don't need to
read the ad I don't need to because I
actually buy this product I'm not one of
those fake-ass podcasters that are
robotically reading ads for products
they don't even use I'm authentic ever
Lane
I ordered a blazer that was gray very
Diane Keaton blazer and then a blue
shirt I wore under it wore it on dr. oz
show am I allowed to say that and these
really happened it's on my Instagram I
looked fantastic I look like Katharine
Hepburn was going to a business meeting
I don't know that's kind of my look with
a Verlaine only makes premium essentials
using the finest material without
traditional markups they want you to
know what you're paying for and why
you're paying for it they don't you
don't have to pay the bills of all the
models today I'm saying and there's no
labels on it so you're not walking out
covered in a bunch of labels looking
ridiculous and desperate
no matter your style your preference
ever lanes clothes look better cost less
and last longer right now you can check
out our personalized collection at
everland com I'm saying our because I've
joined the company Everland comp /
Whitney plus you're gonna get free
shipping on your first order that's ever
Lane comm / Whitney go on my Instagram
and see how cute I looked in that blazer
I really did look amazing ever lane comm
/ Whitney tada there was a great so
there's a great talk on Netflix about
Jared Kushner you know and he owns his
real estate companies Trump son-in-law
and he you know he's like was there the
most aggressive about getting their
money back like they put a body about
they attach a body well I forgot to
determine it but it's to the lien that
they put on you they attach like a body
thing which means they can put you in
jail it's essentially debtors prison
there's very very few people do that it
acts like a body lien to you where they
can literally pick you up and arrest you
for late rent or whatever fun so when
they put a lien like on your house right
so jet like Jared and by the way this is
not even back rent this is like late
fees where you pay your rent but it's
three or four days late they'll just
take a late fee enroll at month-to-month
and you know they're fun so what what
the coup so they went into this
apartment complex where the Kushner's
are evicting these people and you know
for like for like nothing like late fees
they paid the ramp and then and there's
slumlords and you and the apartment is
horrible and it's disgusting in it
there's these two chubby people sitting
on the couch and they go who'd you guys
vote for in the election and they go
Trump and they go why and they go he
takes care of business and they're
getting evicted by the guy son-in-law so
it's like at that point you go wow who
are we helping who we help you want this
like you know I hope I want us to bounce
back from this pandemic but I do more
people I mean I go ho ho yeah there is I
mean this is what we desert like this is
who we are we have kids licking toilet
seats on tick tock on this is the ticket
so it's like what are we even doing out
there I mean you know the kids that
don't have corona we're eating Tide Pods
two years it's you know it's done I mean
it's a rat what's next what does this
thing look like in 50 years so I mean
you know that part of the quarantine
yeah is because so many basically to
just keep the er's right what manages
people will go snowboarding right now
kill them right here so a lot of this
quarantine is just to keep the people
who can't stop breaking their elbows on
lime scooters 100% yeah so that
essentially the ers aren't full of a
bunch of people that did too many
edibles and decided to run jump to
fucking jump into their pool for their
live streams yeah number of people that
are injuring themselves - talking
fucking twitch right just trying to get
more followers right yeah you know yet
it's a rough time I mean - ruff - Duncan
Trussell before the fall of live comedy
was that the company's darling a couple
of months ago we're doing this bit about
Lyme scooters he had a friend that's in
the art and he's in the ER he said that
his friend who's a doctor said because
of Lyme scooters were seeing civil war
style injuries Wow
like hole that's so falls in people's
chests so true people's jaws are hey
unhinged yeah I mean so we can't have
any of that right now why people are
going in with a virus how long do you
think this lab
this quarantine shelter-in-place it
lasts as long as we don't do it
interesting so I my guess is the sooner
we just do it yeah for real
the less time it's gonna be like
anything yeah and do you are you cooking
are you like being holistic about the
whole thing do you know me at all no I
mean uh we're best friends and strangers
simultaneously but I feel like you are
yeah I'm cool
I'm doing very simple I I'm like I've
been living in quarantine my whole life
I want you don't you take out you're not
that I haven't been doing that kiss okay
I just don't and you don't eat meat at
all I do sigh when I'm on the road right
I because I had eating stuff everyone
knows that I go I try to not get too
crazy about whatever crazy about it I
just feel better my skin is better I
don't eat meat or dairy dairy if I take
off dairy my skin looks great and I look
amazing dairies let's roll let's roll
amazing back my skin is bad my people
always ask me about my skin for some
reason which i think is so weird because
I feel like it people will say the key
of such amazing skin I also think I lie
about my age and I'm 54 so I don't pick
a lane you're very young
do you think you know how many people
say that they're like wouldn t coming so
successful very young really still yeah
really
people like she's not she's not that old
she's like very young well I think
people thought I was lying about my age
for long well you're accomplished you've
done a lot you have like a lot of
specials like people think that that's a
career like a long career but yeah I'm
it's a long career but it's not like a
you're not like 56 yeah yeah I'm 37 yeah
crazy thank you
yeah I think that I like so weird
because what do you make of the fact
that like what did you hear about think
about me before you knew me um very type
A which is interesting yeah cuz that's
nothing wrong in a negative way an
ambitious ambitious always hurts my
feelings a little bit me know always
very very type-a like gets it done no
bullshit
nah not me not like dick yeah but like
very like yeah boom boom boom boom boom
well I think I feel like I really had to
be that because III it really nettles me
when someone's like you're so ambitious
you're sure it's just like I work twenty
minutes a night right yeah but you also
you white shows of course shows I mean
it's a whole thing I think in the
beginning and I'm curious what you think
about this I was so desperate to not
come off gendered at all I never wanted
to hang out I never want to flirt with
comics like the first time I heard of
you not heard of you but the first time
was like when you had to show on NBC and
then there was like some weird
you got like blowback for whatever
reason yeah I don't know why there was a
multicam people were like tweeting and
it was everywhere the people were
tweeting like fake whitney prom or some
BS i pain was horrendous yeah okay and I
was 28 yes yeah that was the first time
I kind of was like it was like they
marketed it like a shitty sitcom it was
like purple font like you and me yes
we're like mmm wagging our fingers at
the camera like this is before I knew
that if you're at a photo shoot for a
sitcom like don't catch the beach ball
right they are gonna throw you a beach
ball don't get your hands on your hips
they can tell you to wag your finger at
the camera they say like look mad look
annoyed and then yeah you know make a
face and you look like you're starring
in front like I was always like I feel
like I saw that and they're people that
were like sounds like what even it like
I'm like what is yeah why do people came
I saw a poster for a sitcom that was
ubiquitous called like Lindsey I would
be clowning so hard that was like that
was anything but there you shoot my name
yeah but the perception of you is like
oh but she's got a sitcom and I'm you
see that's like that's a success as a
comic as a young car yeah that's a
successful comedian so I never knew you
as somebody that wasn't like truly doing
doing things yeah big thing yeah and I
mean I think it's just such an
interesting thing because you know now I
feel like with podcasts like you know
work ethic is being valued again but
when I started it was like if a woman
worked too hard it was like there was
something gross about it kicki like
she's ambitious right right still is
yeah I get a lot of that energy at me is
like what do you do why do you have to
work so much I'm like I you know I was
raised by a single mom and then I lived
with two aunts right all they did was
work and everyone brought their work
home like my aunt
worked at a home for what do we call
people that have Down syndrome now
developmentally challenged yeah I think
so it'll be different tomorrow so yeah
today yeah well she worked with people
that had Down syndrome we're gonna soon
we're gonna call them off the ventilator
that's what we're calling them call them
plug pulled that's you know that's
coming um and she would bring them home
and she they live with her you know she
tried to find them jobs today and when
it was at capacity
it's like I just grew up watching women
work all the time so I don't I've never
thought about it it's like this is just
what you do so you know right I on a man
yeah yeah yeah though if I didn't work
hard and had like a successful boyfriend
I'd be a gold-digging whore right I work
hard I'm like an ambitious whore it's
interesting it's it's hard to to
especially because like you know you
look at how one would say that about
John Mulaney no no one would say like
John Mulaney is so ambitious no no no I
wouldn't use the word ambitious cuz that
always has a negative connotation or
strategic is another one that people
always say that has a negative
connotation when they say like people
people like you laced purses strategic
or calculating that usually means in the
comedy world that they're like they
figured some thing out that you all we
all haven't figured out it's like no you
could just work hard and be funny yeah
that's also an option yeah but those are
teach ik about getting a fucking
notebook and he'll just be funny yeah
just be funny that's all
no one hashtag a great time that our job
is like that's what it's our job is you
know show III think that like that
because the world is changing that
that's gonna change too yeah but it's as
of now there's still some you know
blotch media is too much social media
for a comedian is if it's good if you're
putting out stuff that's good like I
don't do it like I do these little
videos on Instagram they're funny I put
them out on Twitter they're funny we try
to put them out when they're funny so
it's like if we do to in a month grade
if we do for in a month grade if we do
one in a month
great they're all they all have to be
truly funny we're not gonna just do one
a week
if it's not funny yeah that's the way
I've always felt that's what I felt
about everything like everybody like I
took all these social media guys are
like so the schedule that we put out one
stand up clip every Wednesday at 11:00
and I'm like hey some weeks were not
some which we will I want people to just
be like oh that thing is really funny
yeah not like be I don't want to be
married to any type of algorithmic
schedule because to me long term it's
more important that like I could get
short-term bumps yeah in an algorithm
with social media me long term it's more
important that my fans stick with me and
say oh this guy's doing stuff we still
consider funny have you ever said
something on your podcast anywhere where
you were like that was too far like I
don't even have that muscle yeah I do
like I you know I so I made a joke about
Billy Eilish
that I I didn't know she was 17 and I
didn't this was not a nice thing I said
she looked like somebody Harvey
Weinstein kept in a dungeon or something
and it was because she has these very
strange videos where she's bleeding in
Iraq yeah yeah yeah she's talented with
a gun people are on some new shit that
we won't see it is what it is that's
just not my you know it's not I mean
it's she's a lovely woman and whatever
and you know I love her songs say I love
get me or whatever so yet so it's very
uplifting isn't it so so whatever it is
is like ah but I didn't mean to say that
and then a lot of people my like fans
people like hey I really like your show
and I always think you're funny but this
is like an underage girl she's like a
young girl so I'm like I thought she was
35 late 20s like Reza
she has lyrics about hooking up like
isn't a lyric in bad guys she goes make
your dad know there's a lyric and I love
this song so much first of all there's a
lyric that says why does she think I'm
the bad guy maybe it's because I'm
wearing your Cologne yeah and I'm like
Cologne is that said something at 70
meter and she goes I'm a something type
I'm the type to make your seduce your
dad right something like seduce your dad
huh I did not think this was a child
yeah so I thought I got thinking a joke
about an adult yeah yeah yeah I would
not the show I
think now she I believe is in the doll I
guess but I wouldn't like cuz listen
kids should be able to be kids yeah and
do whatever they're gonna do I I could
still say I'm not in love with the or or
the mother I'm gonna say something
weirded out by it but I shouldn't I
shouldn't have made that joke at about
her yeah because I didn't realize how
old she was and I would apologize that's
a good thing where it's like I'd never
apologize for like humor or whatever yes
but if she if I bumped into her and it
was not that she's seen it or heard
about it but whatever if if I would say
oh yeah that was wrong of me to do I
didn't know you were seventeen year old
kid yeah I shouldn't have made a
statement like that about Harvey
Weinstein it was like not right yeah
that's the one time yeah that I would
walk something back because somebody's
like I just didn't know yeah yeah that's
interesting yeah have you ever had
someone made fun of someone on the show
and they messaged you no no I mean
people have told me there are people
that don't love me I say well there's
you know I've said things about whether
they're motivational speakers on
Instagram I said things about people and
I've made jokes about people on
platforms much larger than my own and
well these people know that what I'm sad
but I'm a comedian and if you're if you
behave yes in an absurd and ridiculous
manner I should it's my job sir yeah
when you're when you are doing that it
doesn't mean that you're not don't have
value as a human being or whatever or
I'm not saying your whole thing's you
know but some some stuff is wild so
they're what surprises me is that there
are people I know some people that say
like famous people I mean a few of them
have like listened to the show because
they kind of like when I rip on maybe
Hollywood in general that's like people
I would be surprised at certain people
listen were people like oh this person
listens I kind of be surprised I'm
surprised to hear that really and I've
been out in restaurants and I'm not
gonna say who but like I've been out
restaurants where people have come up to
me that are like really well-known
people that say I like your podcast I'm
like that's weird and I would never in
my life think that that person would
listen to my podcast in Hollywood love
to think that they're not the problem in
Hollywood yeah or a lot of people made a
good point it's like some of these
people are so famous they think it's
hard for them to have regular lives it
also whine a lot that's and they like
maybe relating to regular lives like
through like listening a podcast yeah
yeah I mean it's it's interesting and
it's been I mean the last two years has
really revealed a lot of the brought
yeah yeah in this business and it's it's
weird because it's like I in the last
special I mean I actually cut a couple
things truly the day I was shooting
because I was like oh I'll never work in
this business again if I say that right
it was basically about you know because
it was sort of about some of the me to
stuff and it was about a lot of the
people that were the shittiest to me
yeah Hollywood being women and it was
just kind of like I just don't think
people are ready to have this
conversation yet it's just premature
right I'm gonna get killed for this yeah
and I that conversation still isn't
being had yeah and now with the pandemic
it won't biggest problem internalized
misogyny that women carry around it's
like get me medicine you know yeah it's
gonna be a little different all those
conversations being put on hold we used
to not be touching because of the mean
to climate now it's crazy I walked in
here the guy's got a mask I get it you
know I know people I didn't expect I
mean comedians look it wasn't safe out
there before all this we have been deep
throating microphones that we've been
sharing with read comics for years our
immune system and I was always that guy
that was I was never like a germaphobe I
was always like I'd always wash my hands
oppression with you I always be hygienic
but I was never like a germaphobe where
I was always just like hey might your
immune system like I don't want to cut
myself off so I would never be pure
Elling no never am i used to be you're
just putting alcohol into your blood man
I was just like listen it is what it is
like I'm like listen you build up an
immunity through encountering germs yes
that's right and the world is a German
term it's like a little dreck makes
Shrek or something I don't know them
probably the Nazi thing but it means
like a little dirt makes something good
like yeah it builds your we also caught
were sandbox kids yeah I grew up in a
samba I grew up with you I drink from ha
hose where did you grow up I grew up in
DC yeah okay
Georgetown yeah scene of the crime right
but my summers I spent in a place called
Roanoke Virginia
oh yes arm oh that's so I spent swords
that were you fell over the animals yes
Oh up on farms horses the whole thing so
I had this weird dichotomy of being in
Georgetown I the storm I of politics
which is truly why I I was the darkest
energy ever like the Hollywood Hills as
a dark energy but the darkest energy
ever I've ever been is a place called
Colorama which is right yeah it's where
the Obamas live it's right by Georgetown
it's it's a small little Enclave in DC
called Colorama the coy stirs I don't
know I'm gonna look it up look up is it
Foxhall Road cuz you know how like
you're looking when I grew up all of a
sudden neighborhood Wisconsin Street all
those Street like and it just has all
these mansions and it's very dark energy
over there and it's all like oh with a
k' oh yes no I know exactly so this was
that shoe it's called Adams Morgan
they've recently decided to call it
Colorado like that area those few couple
of blocks in there there's a dark energy
there of like something's going on dc's
an incredibly dark energy because it's
people that want power not money not
fame power power and DC is fascinating
you wake up
I remember whenever have to go to the
airport people are up 5 a.m. jogging
jogging everyone in DC wears navy a
color worn in no other states or no
other city first you're wearing navy
it's one of the fittest cities yeah
because everyone is so type a yeah that
they're up working out in the morning
it's just a very intense energy and I
grew up where I grew up it was a lot of
diplomats wives it was a lot of
socialites it's a lot of like weird fake
proximity to power stuff yeah deriving
your value from being close to like a
senator who has one vote yeah it's very
is very strange and there's there's
spies they're like I'm in all that stuff
it makes you what do you mean well I
mean you know it's the if you know if
you're a spy and another you
want to be near power well I know that I
when I baby my because I would babysit
obviously growing up which is so funny
because again when we were kids yeah
our lives were so dangerous we didn't
have Google we did have background
checks like I had babysitter's that were
just like from the street right the main
qualification for our babysitter was
does she live in the neighborhood so we
just had babysitters we didn't know who
they were I just picture like rappers
babysitting you like they're from the
street the parents are like did they
have street cred they're real no
literally just people would stay in our
homes yeah our children that we didn't
go for the sketchy as babysitter's I
just like that way yeah laughter mark
yeah so I babysat this little kid next
to me I had no business doing it I'd no
idea what I was doing but I remember one
time I must have been 11 yeah and people
came to my house to ask me about the dad
a bunch of questions Oh interesting and
so he was I found out later in the CIA
I was Elena and and so they were doing a
background check yes I mean so what's
interesting about any lived in an
apartment which always big once they
don't make any money unless they unless
they start that what happens is after
they've been in the CIA for a while a
lot of them start taking side jobs and
the side jobs pay very well and those
side jobs can be for very wealthy but
he's like Deep Web read it side no no
these are like okay I worked at the CIA
for a few years now and I speak Arabic
I'm gonna go work for Exxon uh-huh or
I'm still in the CIA but I can do some
private work for a multinational
corporation that wants information yes
or a billionaire family that wants
information or needs information for
whatever reason and I can I can become
you know their operational person and
you know because that's what it is it's
all information and leveraging power so
you know CIA people they're trained and
they have a skill set and their skill
set some of them it's you know killing
people to wet work it's in the field and
they're not what it's called what work
is killing people or you know in being
in the field you're you're you're in
action whatever and then a lot of them
are analysts wet things wet coffee at
marquette works but then you know we
could probably be more success there's a
lot of CIA people that are like access
agents where their job is to connect you
with someone powerful and their job is
to make an introduction and their job
isn't that called Riya Oh quiet yeah
that's right acquire information and
stuff like that and so yes so that it's
a DC is very interesting because you're
always in a restaurant you're looking
around and you're like who are these
people really yeah like that's the thing
who are these people really who are the
you know there's some bold-faced names
you might recognize but then you like
who are the handlers huh the you know
the people that are the operators the
people that are behind the scenes making
all this stuff happen where do we land
on the deep state I mean it exists I
mean in terms of like is Trump fighting
it you know that'd be that's the whole
that's the whole question so the deep
state essentially what about the wet
state of the West day yeah the deep
state is just a nexus of powerful
institutions right whether it's the CIA
the FBI the NSA National Security
Council the deep state is made up of
career diplomats that don't get elected
so they're appointed and then keep their
jobs forever
and they're you know essentially it is a
secret government in the sense that like
we don't know who any of these people
are we don't know what they're doing
nobody nobody really approved it but
they exist they're well-funded they have
a lot of you know capabilities they can
do things they have a lot of power so
some of those people are patriotic loyal
Americans are doing great things and
then some of those people are doing
things that are abhorrent and horrific
and will get us in all kinds of trouble
later on you know whether that's
listening your phone calls are spying on
you or abusing their power or you know
their loyalty is not to the people that
live in this country their loyalty is to
the very wealthy interests that want
certain policies and certain people you
know propagated and and and supported so
the whole thing of the deep state is
it's not a monolith right it's not this
one thing it's a collection of people
and institutions like Henry Kissinger's
a guy that's in the deep state because
he's held so many positions in the
government and he's well known to people
that are in the private sector he's just
a permanent fixture he's kind of for a
while was like a kingmaker and then
you'll you'll have like the deep state
will be like it'll be like banks and
come
you've never heard of like there are
there are small financial firms whose
entire job is to advise countries on how
to earn money in war how do you know all
this shit books just articles and books
you read yeah someone just reads now in
the room you know it's just separating
I'm interested in all this stuff because
I'm since a little kid I've always been
interested in like what's really going
on yeah it's really happening and
because I was an actor as a kid I was 6
years old there's an actor from six to
twelve what is that
you're like a famous actor right no I
mean I was at Sesame Street a few times
which is an iconic program it's more
iconic than most things that anyone will
ever do it's the reality it's the
reality
I've always entertained my generation
when I was a kid I was entertaining my
fellow children but no I was never
finished out for like home alone all
that bullshit
yeah audition for a lot of that stuff to
grace under fire I got a second or third
callback for what grace under fire yeah
you know those tapes are out there
somewhere yeah Brett Butler did not
choose me but I got to like second or
third I gots like a I was almost at the
table read with her and then they went
with another kid who was shorter who
looked better next to her Brett Butler I
can't think of someone in this business
that has a worse reputation yeah I mean
yeah I guess so I never met her I know
she's like a big drunk or something
right well I know that when allegedly
yeah no I just know that when all the me
to stuff started coming up all the male
writers I was working with was like a
baller made me fucker what was Logan
Paul's house like it's beautiful I
picture a lot of like it's liar place he
lives like a kid in blank check there's
sneakers and Ferraris strewn throughout
the yard yeah I mean it's a great he's
actually a good case against time he's
like a smart kid and I think those guys
figured something out that comets are
now trying to figure out yeah yeah which
is essentially I mean editing no one
taught Eddings well here's the other
thing there's a great article in the
Atlantic called the death of the artist
and the birth of the creative
entrepreneur it takes you through the
beginnings of art all the way through a
lot becoming like a professional class
thing of like
I get a doctorate in the SN yeah as a
council and there's museums where all
the way up to now where you are you know
the mercy of algorithms and you know all
of that stuff you're an order-taker so
you know they they the content is for
the most part forgettable yeah right but
the way that they've used the medium is
is huge yeah and they should be
commended for that like the idea that
they were able to harness that
technology and then maybe down the road
some of that might get more artistic or
not I mean their contents good content I
don't think it's bad content yeah but
it's forgettable because it's designed
to be I mean they've lost every single
day it's just like here's the thing now
the next thing it's religion I mean it's
replacing religion yeah but they all
have a work ethic that a lot of people
don't have like comics should learn from
those kids because they have an amazing
work ethic and now a lot of them are
sociopaths and don't you know but a lot
of those because they don't know tick
tock they don't blink they don't blink
they just blank you know is dancing in a
replace words well it's interesting
I had a joke about tick-tock where I
said what I love the bat tick-tock is
it's an app we could literally watch
people dance as the world burns I'm
really trying to do tick-tock because I
would resist I'm just a Luddite about
this kind of what you just looked up I
just go I just look at these I'm
interested in the sound panels yeah I'm
like why don't I I have like two I have
the old foam ones real deal but these
are probably very expensive no I think
the whole thing was 1,200 for all of
them okay it's not bad yeah all these
sound panels and then I had the wall
it'd be funny if you were like what you
look Capital much is a bad in the corner
of that room but yeah we'll Danny that's
a great question um what will dancing
one place where we're getting dumbed
down like Liz oh well let's go performed
in front of and I kind of predicted that
somebody showed I said music will just
be a big jiggling ass yes Liz oh the
American Music Awards perform the front
of just a big bulbous jiggling yeah yeah
yeah so it's like that's defeat the face
reason it's smart please read super sad
true love story no it will I'm gonna get
order to it sound sir I'll give you my
copy yeah I'll disinfect it I'll cover
dip it in my salt all right you dog I'll
take a dog and I
copy the book and some of the pool water
panels no but that we will be in this
future dystopia all the bars they're
called the clitoris is the name of like
the bar and it's you walk through a
giant vagina and all the women are
wearing see-through pants they're called
onion skin jeans I mean and everyone
will be living their lives solely for
public consumption and essentially
live-streaming yourself will be like the
new waitressing I mean it's it's
something every lower class person will
have to do which was which I'm I said
weeks ago the only two options for an
economy will be podcasting being a cam
girl so it's either gonna be years old
yeah and I could make whatever five
grand a week just in a bra that's the
only deal I what are you doing it the
only economy left is what we're doing
right now and the double penetration
scene from wet requiem for a dream you
know the last thing that's it those are
your two options so I also I mean I've
gotten a lot of public fights with dan
Bilzerian
but though people are always like how
come you don't go after dan Bilzerian
for the fact that he has those girls at
his parties because if they're getting
paid like who cares I would totally have
done that when I was 21 here's a
thousand bucks to stand in a bikini
right at my birthday party I only go
after him about abusing animals what is
he what did you do with the animals no
he has these parties the bullshit
parties with all these girls why don't
you have tigers and bears tigers and
bears no yes well are they serving
dragon no but I don't think they should
be serving drink and that's wrong and
nobody would be know if a bear came over
with tartare electrocuting the bear what
people don't do is they don't zoom into
the picture and see the electric wire
around where is the bear important are
up and mansion in Bel Air these bullshit
animal trainers that I'm in all kinds of
fights with yeah still do I love that
you start all these problems with people
I like I do like you realize that so you
can rent a bear don't I'm not nobody
this is the kind of money he's gonna
have I don't you out of your mind every
good Adam if you go to Lysa bears or you
can see how bears are trained to do this
stuff and it is horrific people don't
know that was an option
don't bears like riding bikes know the
amount Buse that goes into that why
would you a party there's a bear riding
a bike head go what do we do
why aren't we doing this why are we
putting giraffes in boxes for rich guys
parties yeah that's a little crazy but
that's when we knew that's when I knew
society was over when rich people were
bringing bears I mean just putting
Tigers and cages to be at a rappers I
don't even like Vegas when you see like
a white tiger in a lobby and a little
bomb like all white Tigers are inbred so
what is that they're all inbred so there
are so few white tigers that all white
tigers that are forced to fuck each
other are related to each other that's
why they're all cross-eyed and have
vision impairment you know like on
Instagram and they show like a white
tiger that's cross-eyed and it's like so
funny that's because it's inbred it's
just all white tigers are inbred it's
awful I know I've gone too far down this
wormhole no that's Chris all-white show
they're not real mm-hmm
all white tigers are Berrian tiger I
don't know enough about Siberian tigers
are they still up in functioning I think
so we haven't eaten them all yet have
you ever seen a liger which is a lining
very bit I have I know but they're
pulling a dynamite yeah but that's also
like not good yeah the fact that humans
are just like forcing apex predators to
fuck it so and here's what I'll say I
was think about this a lot before you
came on because I think part of the
reason everyone's so scared right now is
because we're being reminded by how
vulnerable we are yes we have a false
sense of superiority in the animal
kingdom because we have opposable thumbs
yes right we figured out a way to make
locks we figured out a way to make you
know zoos we figured out a way to keep
tigers in but when that's all gone we
are at the bottom of the food chain
right bees can kill us right that's how
pathetic humans are 100% our bad our
being you know taken out by an invisible
thing micro micro can't even see we are
trash bags full of blood right at any
moment so I think that stuff like this
shakes that up a lot yeah it makes us
realize how are you talking to doctors
about this are you reaching out to
people I am I would love to hear about
the respiratory doctor that you well he
just said you know they don't know
anything and you know he was just like
we're running out of stuff it's getting
tough and he was like you know I'm like
I was trying it like I'm like what about
these antivirals and you know he's like
we don't know why are we hearing
anything from Sweden like he goes we
just don't really know who is going to
respond to these things he goes we know
nothing about this disease he goes I
will say one thing
he goes the idea that we thought this
was the flu or likened it to the flu and
said it's just the flu he goes we'll go
down in history is like one of the
biggest misstatements or
mischaracterizations of anything ever
you guys cuz it's not the flu but I do
think humans we need some kind of answer
even if that's not true like self-soothe
hundreds of people growing well it's
just the flu like that's where are your
doctors telling you helpful things
positive things and but they're also
doctors you know I used to date a doctor
who works in the ER and I call him like
every day about this and he's his whole
thing is it's called a practice for a
reason it's not called the Championships
right medicine is doing the best we can
with the information we're so doctors
are always the people that say we don't
know non doctors and ones it's the flu
and the doctors go we don't know yeah
omens in order to manage our terror I'm
really obsessed with terror management
theory which is a good thing I think to
study right now the warm at the core is
a good book if you want to learn about
terror management theory about how we
need rituals we need trophies we need
sort of delude ourselves because we're
the only species that knows we're gonna
die interesting so in order to manage
our terror about that we have to have
clubs and groups and yeah herbs and
cowboy versus the Patriots we need teams
we need to align the other we need to
put ourselves on pedestals that the sort
of things our brain that's all because
we know we're gonna die terror
management cuz we're all afraid we need
some kind of indelible meaning does a
bear not have any clue he's gonna die a
little bit an elephant they're smart
they go visit the grave that's true so
the elephants and even they say
squirrels have a concept that they will
go hungry they hide their acorns they
usually I remember where the fuck their
acorns are right but the evolutionary
benefit of that is a lot of times they
forget to where they bury their acorns
and it plants trees so so elephants are
smart enough to know things elephants I
believe the top five smartest animals it
goes humans dolphins elephants pigs dogs
that's emotional intelligence what about
cats cats I am NOT and people think that
I'm like not a cat person I just don't
know that much about cats from what I
understand about cats
what I like about I don't have a lot of
intelligence they're very evil and
vicious like they are they don't tell
all if it was bigger it would kill you
like if the cat was decided the tiger
would murder a purse it doesn't like you
like what's great about is like my I I
don't I make a lot of content with this
cat whose oh yes yes cat he's not my kid
whose cat is no it's my friend Michels
cat Thank You blocks with Oscars just
this big grey cat he escapes from the
house all the time he's horrible he
breaks it vicious well cats are
incredible predators but he has no
you're like you know I'll be holding him
and he'll just go on my face I go he's
trying to kill me it's hilarious because
he's little but if it was bigger it
wouldn't because he'd be killing it like
yeah he's so I mean I don't think he has
any respect for human life or anything
well they the ones that are domesticated
I mean look it's very I'm very
fascinated by our epigenetics and what
we're bred to do I mean certain cats are
bred for certain things it's amazing
that they worship them in Egypt and
stuff all that sounds very interesting
to me worshipped cats this Savannah cat
yeah actually one of these came across
because now whenever there's a animal
that needs to be rescued people send it
to me and someone's like we have this
Savannah cat that someone needs to give
up the cat Justin Bieber has okay which
is essentially one if I've grant yeah
they're unbelievable and this guy sends
me a video where he's like and cats
again it's just not my network I got a
dog I can get you a dog yeah I can get
an elephant I can get most animals cat
is just not I usually Bester and that's
her thing she's very good at it I just
don't have the network of people like
rosebud Baker texted me the other day
comedian she's like there's a cat on a
roof can you help me I'm like I don't
have anyone for that yeah if it was a
dog I'd have 20 people yeah so it wants
to be on the roof yeah I'd like to get
away from it throw some food up there
look at the news you're gonna be on the
roof it's not real soon
here's what I'll say I don't know this
is why the room not even a play I want
to read right yeah yeah yeah cats can
survive without us oh yeah so rush
limbaugh said wants guys have conned
humanity into feeding
you've added that's why you had a cat he
loved his guy him twice tried to rescue
cats yeah first time I rescued a cat it
was on the street I brought it inside I
fed it I washed it tried to give a cat a
bath was a harrowing experience I then
put it on Instagram to find it a home 30
minutes later my neighbor shows up at my
house and was like did you just put my
cat on Instagram I was like oh my god oh
my god I kidnapped her cat that's
hilarious
it was outside like angry or thought oh
well she was like what are you doing and
I was just like oh I saw a cat outside I
thought it was supposed to I didn't
realize they were allowed to be outside
the next time I turn on Oscar who is
outside everyday walks around goes in
people's yards
coyotes are like no thanks this
motherfucker is not playing well he
lives in West Hollywood so there's no
coyotes got it yeah and then another
time I was driving home at like midnight
from the store and I see a cat in the
middle of the road and I had seen a
coyote up on Mulholland yeah I get out I
get the cat the cat starts puking in my
car shits in my car I take it to the
24-hour hospital yeah it gets so we get
the chip we call the woman the woman's
like can you please the it's clear that
the people at the hospital they've heard
that when cats get older they and they
know they're gonna die they leave
interest to go die somewhere else right
and I kept bringing it to the ER and
they're like you have to just let this
cat die like it's gonna keep leaving the
home
the woman had eight people yeah bring it
to the ER over the past two weeks cuz
the cat kept trying to leave and died
why does it do that why does it hide I
know else that's just such an
interesting isn't it because I what cat
people told me was they don't want to
burn their owners although it is not
fully known why some cats go away to die
it is likely that when our cats become
very old and feel unwell they prefer to
die alone and rest
unlike people cats do not anticipate or
know about death as we do say they are
not fearing what might happen
interesting well this got dark that's
got darker than the plague talk about
the pandemic now we're like why did cat
stop well it's interesting
I love to do do you ever go on to Google
and Google the beginning of a question
to see what the most asked questions on
Google are no but I know that people do
that that's how we're gonna do like how
many cheetahs can fit it up just to see
like whatever people are asking the
Internet right yeah it gives you like a
good sort of sample of what scholars
like there's a guy that I do about
podcast with he has a joke about that he
comes on my podcast occasion of this guy
Raycom pussy yes you call it me yeah
he's nuts and then he goes he had a joke
about that where he goes he goes yeah
he's like anything's always on Google
like how many Cheetos are in a fish tank
he goes am I the only one the only one
googling is that all making me gay he's
like that's it he's like I'm the only
one who's flaccid dick and amphetamine
frenzy you try it you know so like
that's that question makes me think of
that job I used to joke about this ages
ago
this is how old the joke and yeah it had
the word midget in it Wow I did this
joke on the George Lopez Tonight Lopez
Tonight it's an old one - yeah and I
remember I was doing a joke about what
happens when you fill in the blanks and
I one night Google do midgets yeah to
see what people were asking about
midgets and none of them were are we
allowed to use the word midget yeah and
the number two question was do midgets
have night vision
I love the collective consciousness of
that country okay so let's see if we can
answer some of these questions so I'm
asking can Corona does that feel like a
good yeah root yeah can Corona number
one ask question about chronic and
coronavirus live on clothes interested
yes yes put him in the fucking washer
when you get home King Cronus spread
through the air answers yes yeah can
corona survive heat Rogen was talking
about this yeah supposedly the amount of
heat that you'd have to turn a sauna up
to or drink the amount of liquid to kill
the corona would also kill you if you
breathed in that level of heat but no
extreme heat probably not yeah we're
still waiting to see if the spring and
summer months help transmit right they
committed in we're still waiting to say
we don't know no one knows people think
it might can coronavirus spread through
food
great question hmm I don't know I would
say that your stomach acids kill a lot
of stuff but what do I know
a lot of this stuff we don't know yet
yeah what steps the future supposedly if
you drink aids blood you you won't get
because you're a stirrer acid in your
stomach burning up
I'm not saying to do it but your stomach
gases are very powerful you know the the
joke I've gotten in trouble for the most
yeah in my life
yeah is uh it was a joke that did you
like the roasts I thought they were
great recipes roasts it was a joke that
it was one of those jokes that I
remember telling it yeah and there was a
vid silence and I thought I was gonna
bomb right then everybody laughed
afterwards right for Pam Anderson I've
since apologized to pay management for
this joke publicly many times but I said
Pam Anderson you've dated Bret Michaels
Tommy Lee and Kid Rock why don't you
just save some time and drink of out of
Magic Johnson's blood that's funny that
roast of Pamela Anderson I think was the
best roast that was that's my favorite I
wrote for that I didn't
this was honest also would become the
roast of Courtney Love that's correct
that was amazing 20 love look worse in
Kurt Cobain Jeff Ross got up he goes
down boy girl whatever like it was just
an amazing brutal brutal and Tommy leave
is that right yeah does Corona have
gluten oh that's the beer okay
does Corona cause sore throat dry cough
try cough but you know what here's the
other thing what they don't know like
you could have a wet cough it still
happens but we need a false sense yes
one thing sure this press attention I
agree when is the last time we didn't
know something about a virus say it is
yeah it's that didn't go so well not
really and we're gonna have Corona the
musical 525,600 right now it's gonna be
fine bodies in what a nightmare but
that's what's gonna happen you know
well Cronus will Corona end the world
okay you guys are getting a little dark
out there
it will certainly upend the world order
I mean you know it very possibly could
be a prolonged period of economic
fallout and it could be a lot worse
people think here's what I think it's
the first manageable pandemic like
Spanish flu was not managed now at all
no I think that this can be managed that
being said you know it's a the world
differently I don't think the world
comes back you know I think the world
emerges very differently and like a lot
of these gathering like so for example
like you know I'm from New York City
they have these buffets of food oh you
like those days over I mean like in I
love those they're great I think in food
from all the same place are they making
it they're making it okay but like you
know my face in Vegas we're still gonna
have shrimp of phase with pudding and
cottage cheese I don't know that's what
I'm thinking I'm what should we ever
have had them no you know what I mean is
that ever a good idea that's what I mean
like you know how many people were
getting plenty of viruses from Coachella
how different do things look how
different do things look after this so
tonight I think I mean are you ever
going to I mean I don't take cruises and
I don't I mean the people have sex again
yeah and there are the people who take
cruises are like whatever its core tasks
how do you get on infuse again people
there's still people booking cruises
just like $25 not a cruise around the
world I think there is something look
America loves nothing if not a good sale
yeah and if not a good deal right and I
mean I get it I get I mean last week I
was like dude now is the time to go to
Europe
yeah I mean in every room people that
I've seen you're sort of like it's not
gonna happen to us we don't be fine yeah
best thing I can do is get out of this
country and yeah you know why do you
think happening Scandinavia I mean it
will very small not hearing anything
else we want our way small in
populations of people um I don't know I
don't really know how much can we trust
the information coming out of China
not a lot we're going it's curved in
China I'm like I don't you believe I
gotta be honest with you I don't think
it has I believe it has not and I
believe that they don't have twitter
yeah they are not two people in check a
lot of the information we are getting
right now is coming from just people on
the front lines I don't think it's
curbed in China I think actually when
they're like Italy's overtaken China I'm
like no it hasn't I mean
I'm sure it's Italy has an older
population first of all I'm sure it's
equally as bad in China though like if
in China people can't they don't have
our Twitter they can't log on to our
Twitter they can't log on to our
Facebook yeah so we don't know I also
think that there's part of this that
could just be the new not not the new
normal in the sense we're all gonna stay
in our houses but like this is a
seasonal yeah or just this is a thing
that's gonna we're gonna have to wait
till we get a vaccine or we wait till
antiviral treatments work is it's not
going away yeah am I just not go away
until the medicine catches up to it
which is terrifying because nobody wants
that nobody wants to wait but people
gonna have to learn to live with it
they're gonna have to learn we need a
system we just need the hospitals not
crashing yeah that's what we need we
need a system to deal with it we just
don't have a system to deal with it we
we're we're very bad in this country at
systems we love people yeah yeah yeah
whether it's a OC or Trump or whatever
we know all about these people but we
know very little about that's what all
these food documentaries you're like you
know they startled Americans and they
shocked Americans and people in other
countries were like hey we know exactly
they're like how this chickens being
kept and it's like people in other
countries like yeah how do you think
your food materializing you're frigging
idiot Americans walk around on a cloud
artificially subsidized yes we don't
know how we get these little dollar
cheeseburgers that someone hands us
through a window we don't know that like
other parts of the world people are
being abused tortured you know
subjugated for those types of things we
don't know what tomatoes cost what they
cost we don't know where our diamonds
come through out no idea about any of
that yeah so a lot of this is startling
for people that are like wait what so we
don't know that the health care system
was wholly unprepared for this yeah the
society's rotted to the core where
unfortunately that book is gonna be the
future like this probably doesn't write
itself and probably just cut the
stratification of society gets worse and
worse until you know they do go to
enclaves and they put up the gates and
yeah well in the future of the book that
that I'm adapting super sad I mean you
walk in and you're sanitized when you
walk into any building right if you're
sick you're sent home right away and a
robot goes with you to make sure you
stay home I mean drones are walking the
dogs you have to everyone's on metformin
I'm excited everyone's doing that shit
it's and you're essentially cholesterol
hydration level
blood sugar is broadcasted on a device
that's and and your what's the word
blood pressure is at all types and
you're essentially insurance knows I
think every choice you make just hears
everything you say and there's even a
trustworthiness score so I love it so
social credit scores you see them in
China was that that's already happening
it's coming it's Tim Dylan is there
anything else we need to cover well
they're a lot more of these it seems
like we did a lot yeah we're here yeah
yeah we're shut down
Tim Dylan Thank You Gavin news what else
do we need to know that was the right
thing right to shut down yeah do we need
to close the beaches who's going to the
beach everyone really in Tampa what was
it was spray with Spring Break you got
to get you got to close the beaches
right now you got to close all public
parks and all that stuff for right now
national parks beaches things like that
and also even if it's not because you're
necessarily gonna get Corona if you
break your ankle if your fucking body
boarding if you go to a park there's a
fucking dog fight at the dog park and
you got to bring your dog to the vet I
mean it's like we just need to reduce
the amount there's a lot of oblems
there's a lot of really smart people
that are very freaked out so what that
tells me is that we are there were a
little bit of trouble and we're not near
the end of it and we got it you know cuz
when you see very intelligent people
that have a lot of money and their and
some of them are verges very smart know
what I was going on I'm like a clown so
I better just stay worried yeah and then
dumb people are at the beach that's
never bored the beach because smart
people are at the beach we can all relax
there's a real death wish in the country
it really is I mean the star win' ISM
it's just a dog does a dog have an
almond yeah you know shit hit the fan
cuz I started eating on the fire shit
there's a real darkness there's a real
darkness how's your keto lon not great
he's not the time for keto wasn't really
not the time for keto
right now depend emic this is not the
time to be peeing on strips you know
like yeah it's like all these digs
for me what's the time to grab a potato
roll and cry into it I think that dish
is not gonna be forever but it's gotta
be for right now and hopefully we all
emerge from this sometime in the spring
and we all start kind of I want to do
spots I want to make people laugh we
might need to go back to smaller venue
more shows in smaller matters because I
will say comedians there's a little bit
I was gonna say epidemic but let's not
say throw that word around of comedians
that wants so badly to show off how big
their venues they can sell out our rhyme
that they're doing there's this clapper
thing where it's like I'm gonna go to
these big venues and when you're doing
such big venues it turns into like ah
anybody ever get married and it's like
whoo it becomes like whoo comedy yeah we
might have to get back to smaller more
intimate venues yeah you know hundred
seats I think that's how it comes back I
think it company eight shows a week I
think it comes back in those types of
venues smaller smaller more European
looking we're all gonna have to appeal
to younger audiences we're gonna have to
change our demo a lot of demos demos
will die that's true that's true a lot
of famous people will come back ian's no
I will not be able to sell out theaters
anymore it'll be interesting so it'll be
interesting to see but hopefully we come
back stronger yeah thank you thank you
for having me
we did it did it thank you I always said
very awkwardly yeah perfect I don't
normally sign off what do you want to
say like I'll say like yeah I'll be like
you know like I'll say something like
nan Sakura I'm like the bodies will burn
in the street and I'll be like good
night
[Music]
[Applause]